this is an oversimplification but here's
how a movie gets made
actors film scenes by saying their lines
and then the director and editors
assemble a kurta using the best takes of
each scene sometimes a messed up take
ends up in the final film because it
still works with the story but other
times bloopers just have no business
being anywhere near the movie
here are some bloopers and outtakes for
movies that never made it into the final
cut for some very easily understandable
reasons Suicide Squad in director David
Ayers manic cartoonish villain aramis
Suicide Squad the usually heroic Will
Smith plays very much against type as
Deadshot a character who's both a hitman
and an expert sharpshooter in other
words he's someone who knows his guns so
he would never do this you guys are safe
shots of Will Smith bungling the process
of loading occur might make a funny
moment in a different film but it never
would have worked for the character
named after his ability to shoot things
bad mom's NFL defenseman JJ Watts has
started making the move into showbiz and
he's a pretty funny guy who usually
seems as comfortable on screen as he
does smashing into other behemoths on
the gridiron in bad mom's he plays a
soccer coach who bears some of the brunt
of Mila Kunis's character rage and in
one take she so convincingly Burson to
what Sophists are the otherwise macho
dude seems genuinely scared
did you say unfortunately the blooper
had to be cuts you can't have your
movies tough guys screaming like one of
the kids he coaches the awkward moment
this millennial comedy is all about the
cringe inducing moment we all seem to
put ourselves through but the most
awkward moment of the movie occurs on a
blooper in just about every framed
poster in a conference room scene comes
loose and falls down
it wasn't planned and is fitting the
awkward as it may have been it kind of
ruins a movie's credibility of the
entire set starts falling apart
on screen scandal most modern Americans
carry their smartphones of them wherever
they go even actors actively working on
a set carry their phones around with
them out of view of the camera and with
a ringer turned off of course well
they're supposed to turn the ringer off
while shooting a scene for scandal
Guillermo Diaz gets a bit embarrassed
when he's interrupted by the sound of
his own phone going off redeye in redeye
Kilian Murphy plays a psycho terrorizing
a woman on the plane it's a tense
pulse-pounding exhausting thriller with
few lighthearted moments and you get the
real sense that Killians character is so
crazy he can't be stopped
he tell the flight attendant and your
dad dies that means that this charming
bit with a little girl threatening to
beat up Murphy just didn't fit in
that guy mugging you cuz I can take him
out in New York the girl is still in the
final film but her apparently improvised
line is nowhere to be seen
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]